هذه بنتي بعد 14 سنه
[موسيقى]
ازرع حسبنا
الله بدر وجل تنفق العالم
ينظر
الشعب
الفلسطيني من 48 والشعب الفلسطيني كل
الدول بتم
عليه حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل على كل من
واحد خذر الشعب الفلسطيني قضيته العالم
ينظر لنا احلى منو من 48 واهالينا تدبحوا
اهالينا بتكتل والشعب العربيه بتتفرج
علينا بسكت وقفات بدونا اح بدنا حك
الزنب الطفله هذ الزنب فيها زي كده هذا
بتحارب الاحتلال هذ ايش زن صير زي كده
اطرافها الاثنين يتقطع زي هيك حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل في الحكام العرب حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل فيكل واحد بشوف اللي بصير
فينا
[موسيقى]
وساك
عار على الشعوب العربيه كلها عار على
الشعوب العربيه المتخد ضد القضيه
الفلسطينيه انا رسالتي
انه ها اطراف يحولوها برا يعدها وبس انا
مش طالبه غير
[موسيقى]
هيك قتلوا اطفالنا وعونا حخل ونجيب ابناء
ونجيب اطفال سائرين يحرروا
فلسطين مش مشكله اطفالنا تموت
بس ينولد عنا اطفال تائر وحجيب الط الشعب
[موسيقى]
الفلسطيني